[Music]
what's up guys this is the lord zombie
coming to you live from day two at pax
east 2022
um we're here
at
mega cat studios
and we're going to look at world boxing
we're champion boxing manager too
now the original game came out
many many years ago yeah this is andy
from the dare team andy tell them about
yourself
uh involvement with the game and also
what the game is about yeah sure so i'm
andy marsh i'm one of the designers and
artists for world championship boxing
manager 2 as well as other games from
mega cat studios the original world
championship boxing manager came out in
1990 on dos ibm compatible vcs
we're making a sequel to it 30 years
later
we're trying to sort of simplify some
things about it that people didn't like
and then take some other things to make
them a little bit more interesting
so now on this new version of it you're
not just hiring boxers you're hiring the
training staff
you're hiring their medical staff you're
hiring therapists for them if their
stress levels get too high
and so you know you're booking matches
they're taking place in tournaments and
you're just basically trying to get your
boxers to win matches make money improve
your facilities and build better boxes
out of them that's amazing so tell me in
terms of like a story mode like the
overall story mode are you building your
boxer from the ground up completely like
this guy is a kid that walks into a gym
and wants to become the best in the
world and everything that has to do with
that sort of upbringing is included in
this game when it comes to like picking
managers the the wheeling and dealing
that goes on behind the scenes all of
that is included in this game yeah so we
have two two modes in it we have an
open-ended career mode exactly like
you're saying you're picking guys up off
the streets they want to be the best in
the world training them up to beat just
that we also have a story mode in the
game where you're going to be
training or managing real life boxers
like sugar ray robinson
and rocky marciano and you're gonna be
managing throughout the real life three
years trying to hit certain milestones
they hit in real life to finish out
their career like they did in real life
that's amazing so tell me how many uh
how many license boxes do you have in
the game so right now launch we're gonna
have those two uh post launch content
we're planning on adding a lot more
that's amazing so are they going to be
giving you sort of uh like tasks during
the course of your career to sort of
improve like their careers
additionally to sort of get xp for your
own career yeah yeah so that's exactly
how it's gonna work we have a milestone
set you have to hit for the different
box like for the real life license guys
you have like certain milestones that
they hit in the real lives that you're
gonna have to hit in their careers in
the game okay so in terms of improving
like their stats and stuff like that how
does that gameplay mechanic work
all right so you got you got your gym
that you have set up and so you use that
to plan out the training regimens for
the week to raise up the stats speed the
strength stamina
and as you win as your boxers win
tournaments you get money you can
improve those facilities
so you can learn you can have them learn
new training exercises they can learn
new skills that you can use in matches
and
you know raise their skills much faster
okay in terms of like picking managers
and picking promoters and stuff like
that how does that mechanic work so
you're handling all the management
promotion in the game so you're the
manager and when you've got a fight
going up you can promote it if you
promote a fight it'll give your guy a
little bit more of an edge than before
because he's coming in all amped up for
the promotions
um you can choose not to do that because
when you're starting off you got no
money you know you're just in some back
alley gym somewhere
so is this is this a straight simulation
or does it uh sort of
make a little one of like the back you
know the behind the scenes stuff like
you know shady promoters and stuff like
that do you have that sort of mechanic
in the game there's a little bit of that
we try to so
one of the things about doing a
simulation game is it's really easy to
turn that into an excel spreadsheet we
didn't want to do that you know we want
to make sure we have a little bit extra
character to everything that's why we
got the great pixel art and everything
yeah that's 32-bit art style like really
bring a little bit more character out of
it yeah it looks absolutely amazing it
looks like something that again
a game that's still 20
so we're making it all in unity and
we're expecting it to come out um
we're shooting for early summer in early
summer release and what about planning
uh everything it's gonna be uh pc xbox
playstation
controller
the other reason is
nailing everything down to
a controller control key for a simple
class controls especially for fewer
actual players for like a simulation
game it's really good um
the game looks absolutely amazing
from the very bottom
you can find us online on all circles at
megacad studios
studios.com gabe's world championship
manager
oh
final build of the game we have um
commentary so looking forward to that
that's gonna be great
i don't think he's at the booth right
now our boy does all our vo for us he
does a fantastic job
yeah
[Music]
it lets us like play around with the
business side of things with these ugly
sports a little bit more which is like
compelling in their own way you know
yeah it is
[Music]
inside baseball
anywhere yeah
[Music]